Lit, sick, lit, sick, lit, sick.
What up fam? It's me, Forest Lawns.
I'm Grace's cousin; I've been on this channel once before.
You guys like savage request to have me back. That's so savage and lit. [Savage lit]
What do you call a f* boy's favorite class?
SAVAGE LIT
Sorry I was too smart for a second. I will retract my previous joke.
I realize that people on YouTube have been naming their fanbases as if to create some sort of like pseudo-militia.
It's a little bit concerning, but the thing that I'm more concerned about
is that we don't have a family name. But I gotchu!
I'm Forest Lawn. You guys are my overly-obsessed fans,
So I'm gonna call you "Lawns Gnomes."
Like the sh*t you get at Home Depot or Lowes. Lit, lit, lit, lit, lit, lit! Stomach ache.
I'm working on music.
Speaking of music, my boy, Jake Paul released a diss track/not diss track.
I hear it is sh*t. The sh*t. Freudian slip.
Too smart- I'll retract.
I haven't seen it, so I'm gonna watch it and react to it with you guys right now.
LAWNS GNOMES
Jake Paul, YouTube star's diss track. Oh! In the thumbnail he's got photos of all these huge YouTube stars,
and I bet that's super misleading, and like none of them are even mentioned.
"This isn't a diss track, It's a message to all the news and hate."
Jake- Oh! He can write in cursive!
We're both wearing... sports!
Do you see how strong his knees are? It ripped through both jeans.
He got strong knees. Prolly from suckin' all that dick! Just kidding, what? Pussy!
Oh! Oh, he's shopping in the liquor aisle! He's in the liquor aisle!
You know some o' the firest of fire tracks have been shot inside a grocery store!
Oh! Important! He's like the only kid from a small town, so he's been through struggle.
No one else is from a small town the way that Jake Paul is from a small town.
Oh, I feel the struggle!
Oh.
"In a noose."
We're gonna keep going.
Oh, oh! Wait, did you see that?
He said the word "b*tch" verbally, but in the subtitles he put stars.
But he said it. But he censored it in the titles.
Cuz deaf people, he cares about.
Oh, lit! Fire, lit, fire, lit, fire.
I don't know your password.
I didn't get invited directly.
It seems like you were the only person there doin' meals for kids on Thanksgiving, so...
I gotta give that to you, and only you, that you were the only person there.
Makin' charity meals for kids on Thanksgiving.
And you're probably the only person that's ever done that ever in the world.
I didn't get invited.
But you handin' out backpacks and t-shirts to those kids- infinitely more charitable than what a teacher's
normal, day-to-day job is for the pay that she gets and the work that she puts in
constantly and consistently! Oooh, you're better! Pussy.
Ooh! Using a very sincere situation and manipulating it to make you look better
rather than shine a good light on a great cause! Ooh!
And then straight back to the aluminum aisle of the grocery store like it never happened!
Oooh! Illegally driving your car!
In a video that's supposed to make you seem nice and good. Confusing messaging!
Lit, fire, lit, fire!
You got Rihanna on this track?! What?
Whoa. You just said that you know you're cocky and you're trying not to be.
But the visual imagery was you drivin' illegally with your car
in a way that suggests you are encouraging dangerous activities.
Ooh! Continuous mixed messaging!
We didn't go to school together.
You were probably the only one in the lunch room I would assume, cuz you're the only one from a small town
that had small town struggles. But apparently had other kids in your town that you stopped from gettin' bullied.
You weren't gettin' bullied, it sounds like, in your small town. So maybe your life was actually pretty good
to begin with, and the struggle might be just some sort of delusion in your head or some sort of shallow
attempt to get sympathy? I don't know! I'm just spitballin' here! Like, this track lit, fire, lit, fire.
Oh I talk so much sh*t to Selena when she left Disney!
She just didn't tweet me back.
No.
That we only know what you put on the internet for us. Otherwise, it's called stalking.
You!
HPV
He's not even crossing on the crosswalk!
This kid lives life dangerously! He's wearing two different color shoes!
Let's just finish it.
Oh! And a link to buy the song!
Because if you're gonna apologize genuinely and want people to sympathize with you being a human being,
make that CASH MONEY!
Don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel, if you want more videos,
let Grace know that you want Forest Lawns to be back with more content for my Lawn Gnomes.
That's it, I gotta go cuz I'm too amped, lit, fire, fire, pussy,  dick, fire, pussy, lit.
I'm gonna say somethin' I regret, so before I do that, I'm gonna go find a group of friends
that are slightly above-average attractiveness and see if I can manipulate them into making me money!
I don't know.
Sorry, Gnomes! Just had to admire the beauty that is my face for a second!
Just wanna feel what it's like to be you!